our next question is from Leanne hi gang
it's Leanne from wilbury Pennsylvania
again I would like to talk about holiday
traditions and discuss the real cost of
such traditions for example Thanksgiving
dinner my mother who in her mid 70s
initially felt the need to serve eight
plus dishes because she said it's what
we do she knows I've been following your
podcast and she was open to hearing me
out in reference to the real cost
of such a feast not only the money but
time spent shopping preparing cleaning
up
Etc I then reminded her that she's
always in the kitchen after the meal
tolling with this and that while
everyone else is lounging around and
spending time together she misses out on
the true meaning of the holiday which is
being together with family she
appreciated my perspective and decided
to ask all to bring a dish to help out
this year don't get me wrong some
traditions are worth preserving but you
have to figure in at what
cost I think the sense of keeping up
such traditions still falls mostly on
women and it shouldn't thoughts and
thanks take care I definitely have some
thoughts about the lives that were told
through tradition quite often this is
the way we've always done it why are you
doing that that's the way we've always
done it as if that's a good reason to
keep doing something right and the
reason that I wanted to talk about this
question today is in the book Alex I
mean it sort of question that assumption
if we keep doing things the way we've
always done it we end up at a dead end
oh we've always we've always driven this
way wait if you keep driving that way
there's a giant brick wall you're going
to run into and I mean quite literally
you're seeing that in the book and I
won't give any spoilers here but um
we're driving toward as Dr Bush talked
about an Extinction event but it's also
about my life right now as well and I'm
continuing to drive this way because
this is the way we've always done it now
I'm not against tradition just for the
sake of being againsta I'm not anti-
tradition but we never well we rarely
stop to question some of those
traditions and I think that's when we
end up in well in these Troubled Waters
yeah uh actually a lot of the book is
about this family realizing it's the
process of realizing that what doing
isn't working on several levels not only
you know the the modern day farmer in
this book but his family and people that
he's close to what they're doing isn't
working and uh it's very difficult to
get out of those ruts right momentum is
is a real thing and so and there's
generational momentum and and there's
momentum with within ourselves where
we're we've always done things a certain
way there there comes a point in this
book which isn't a spoiler alert where
um this farmer is confronted with the
fact of you know there's a better way to
do this that's better for you it's
better for your mental health it's
better for the soil Health it's better
for everybody and he's stuck in it and
he's he's saying you know well this is
this is just how we've always done it
like you're saying right and the person
who's confronting them gets real
frustrated cuz that person saying hey
you didn't know better then you know
better now and that's something that
this question is speaking to right if
you know better then it's on you to make
the change right and that's a really
hard break to make sometimes in
relationships in the way you're eating
like whatever it might be but if you
know better it's on you and so what what
she's addressing there is totally
legitimate I mean I remember recently I
read something about how some Norman
Rock whatever what's that guy's name
Norman Rock that guy so so his painting
uh or drawing or whatever of
Thanksgiving what I was reading like
ruined it for everybody because it's
this idilic kind of you know everybody's
around this amazing feast and it's it's
this thing that we're trying to Aspire
to when there's really no basis for that
you know what I mean there there's no
like fact or anything that that's based
on and I agree with the caller like it's
about this this this holiday is about
family not everybody's got it right and
so and I've I've been there too where
been the single guy at Thanksgiving and
wondering you know what what am I going
to do this year there's other things you
can do you can turn it into a different
kind of tradition if you want to hold on
Traditions you can go down to a shelter
and volunteer right you can not even go
to a shelter you can just go to folks
that are having a hard time on the
street and help them out however you see
fit um but this idea of tradition it's
this to me it builds in or feeds into
this this momentum idea which is just so
hard to break you know and it's really I
it's a challenge but I guess my point is
that if if you know better do
better I'm intrigued by your point there
around uh this you know we've always
done it this way and it's so funny when
you realize how short the memory of
humans are because the fact is we
haven't done Thanksgiving like we've
done Thanksgiving for more than maybe
three generations something like that
and it's like well actually for the last
few hundred years it was done much
differently and then we looked at the
agricultural system
we do see Farmers every day with Farmers
footprint my nonprofit were confronting
every day this thing that says well
we've always done it that way and it's
actually just like a quick little 30,000
foot check to say actually did your
great-grandfather do that and he's like
no absolutely no no did your grandfather
do that oh no no actually these
chemicals didn't come out until my dad
so so you're telling me that one and a
half Generations is the norm that you're
now following and feel unable to break
and so we have such short memor spans in
regards to humanity that we don't
remember that for 40,000 years 625
Nations lived here in North America in
coherent relationship to their land and
had a more complex agricultural system
and were producing more food per per
capita than Europe was when the
colonists arrive here they degraded this
land in just a couple hundred years to
the point where it cannot produce
anything without massive chemical inputs
that destroy the ecosystem and so in 200
years destroyed a 40,000 year
agricultural system that created more
abundance the soil was healthier not
less healthy they understood compost
they understand crop rotation they
understand the the resilience and and
importance of not disturbing mycelial
networks in soil and biodiversity within
the crops and all this stuff and
so the again it's this control of our
mentality of what is normal is so
outsourced to our media and to our
consumer Behavior that we have a very
hard time I don't think we're empowered
to ask what's normal and in agriculture
it's hilarious because they call
chemical farming conventional
agriculture it's like that has never
been the convention that's that's a
50-year-old you know Technologic
poisoning of the planet that is not
conventional that's another marketing
term yeah and they've done the same
thing to Medicine suddenly if you're not
practicing pharmaceutical alpath then
you're alternative medicine doctor wait
I'm alternative now to what alternative
to you know history so they've just
branded it so brilliantly that you're
crazy or you're nvo or you're you know
not realistic if you do the thing that's
been done for 40,000 years yeah and
you're you're not Progressive we are
we've progressed our way toward
Extinction we have created a world in
which we are constantly improving not
questioning the improving right if an
improvement leads you like well yeah but
always growing is important well a tumor
is also growth they're great growth you
know if if you go to the gym and you're
working out and you feel like oh my
muscles are growing it's making me more
stable and healthier wonderful right
that's one type of growth but growth for
the sake of growth isn't inherently good
or bad what kind of growth in which way
am I growing yeah it's interesting too
how the concept of a holiday is a holy
day which represents that which a
society deems to be sacred and chooses
to celebrate on that day and we're
creating all of these holy days around
consumerism Taco Tuesday right Mimosa
Monday cyber Wednesday Black Friday and
we're building it into our concept of a
day and we're essentially being
manipulated into treating things that
are dispensable as if they are sacred as
if we could not do without them and it's
changing the way we think about this
idea of how we honor what the real
essence of a day is but you know I when
I think about tradition um I think about
a historian uh I think it's uh jaroslav
Pelican who said that there's a
difference between traditionalism and
tradition traditionalism is the dead
faith of the living tradition is the
Living Faith of the dead and
traditionalism is when you hold on to
something for no other reason than that
that's what the dead people used to do
it didn't save them it didn't help them
but hey the Ancients used to do it but
tradition is when you say we hold on to
this because it's lifegiving it's
transformative and that's why the ones
who came before us did it but we don't
do it because they did it we do it
because of the results it produces in
our lives tradition can never be more
powerful than the why that fuels it and
what I love about Leanne's story and her
question is that she didn't stand back
and condemn she didn't preach she didn't
yell at her but she went to her and
opened her eyes to the same possibility
that she saw so that she could see the
why behind the tradition and then she's
able to honor what is truly sacred about
that tradition in a more direct
efficient way what I hear you saying is
that this is the way we've always done
it is a terrible reason to hold on now
there might be great reasons to hold on
to a tradition that we have but it's not
just because that's the way they did it
yesterday or that's the way they did it
a decade ago quite often that's a
terrible reason to hold on so we can let
go of past traditions and create new
ones that are empowering and serving us
as a family as a community as a habitat
as a planet or we can keep clinging to
the things that weren't working for us
and wonder why we continue to be
miserable every holiday season you know
he brought up a important point that I
want to highlight real quick is that he
was referring to the caller as not
condemning the other person and I think
that's super important cond condemn
doesn't work you know it just doesn't
it's one of those things where um I was
very careful even you know there's some
there's some bad players so to speak in
this book but even those guys you know
the some of these big
corporations they're you can't condemn
them and you can't condemn the people
who who were using the products using
glyphosate for example when that's all
they knew and that's just what you did
and they were told it was safe and
they're like okay you can't condemn
those farmers in 1990 right once they
start knowing better then the
conversation can shift a little bit but
like nothing works with condemnation
Alex you had a story about this you
shared before we start it would you mind
sharing that about how you experience
that exact thing by simply giving
someone the book without telling them
yeah right so I have a friend who works
for a company that is a very large
retailer and uh and they sell a lot of
this particular product that we're end
up end up talking about here and uh he's
a good friend of mine you know he's he's
very he's a conservative Guy and um he's
he's in the South and I sent him this
book and he he took him like a day and a
half to read it and I got an email and a
flurry of texts from him basically
saying oh my God you know and and
because it opened a door for him to go
do his own research and and learn things
for himself the book I think as you said
is not dactic it's not telling anybody
what to do it's just opening a door
right and using storytelling to open
that door and so with this friend who is
like like I said it's the ginormous
retailer of this bad product so to speak
um it got him thinking and it encouraged
him to go do his own research and kind
of make up his own mind you know that's
another thing that doesn't work telling
people what to do doesn't work yeah I
think if you had sent him the book and
said hey Chaz you know what I just
imagine anyone who sells round up his
name Chaz hey Chaz you know what this
book is going to tell you what you
should do yes mhm there are no shoulds
here there are infinite coulds infinite
possibilities of where we can go from
here let me show you the landscape yeah
exactly yeah this book is looking at
kind of the last 30 years and it's going
to help everyone listening here to
really start to account for those hidden
costs that we were talking about earlier
um this is basically my last 15 years of
my life in my basic science laboratory
told through a much better lens which is
through the life of a farmer um so my
basic science began with cancer research
and chemotherapy development and
ultimately took me towards soil health
and realizing that our relationship to
chemical agriculture was driving our
cancer epidemic and no matter how good
their chemo therapy gets we're not going
to win this game of the cancer epidemic
in fact you know every year it's going
to get worse because we're actually in
our unawareness of the problem uh every
one of our consumer behaviors is playing
directly into this equation and so
there's literally not a thing that
you're doing in your life right now if
you you drive your car if you uh go put
on a shirt if you go you
know grab a cup of coffee everything is
playing back into this equation of this
hidden hidden cost which is our
relationship to the chemical industry
and the chemical industry has uh so
imbued itself in our culture that
there's literally not an action you can
take you can't go to your doctor you
can't you know go to your tool without
playing into their hands and that's not
a they of humans it's a they of a human
perception or philosophy and so I I
think this is an exciting book that is
going to open doors in your heart first
which is important because really this
is a story about compassion and when all
of us start to realize that our
behaviors are not just poisoning soil or
poisoning Humanity into our Extinction
we're breaking hearts and I think that
that's probably the most concerning part
to me is that if we go extinct I mean
from a human standpoint we could think
that's a really bad thing but as a
hospice doctor I've never seen a death
that looked like an endpoint it's all
this explosion of realization of who we
are why we here why the journey looked
like it did and the way in which you see
Guilt fear and shame fall away is sit at
the deathbed of somebody who just got to
glance past the the veil and see their
life in the context of the fact that
they actually are nature they are the
fabric of the universe and they can see
the path patterns that just played out
and why they played out and not once do
they move past that veil with fear guilt
and shame carried into that beautiful
future and so if we need this death
cycle if we need the hospice moment and
perhaps the passage of of human life
into our next iteration so be it but
let's be aware and let's be in love with
each other and let's have compassion on
the Heartbreak of the end let's Miss
what is going to be you know
disappearing as we let go of these
bodies and so I'm really excited that
this book is really getting at the
essence of the story of are we going
extinct or not isn't the story is are we
actually in love with life or
not I hope you enjoy that highlight if
you like to see another one check out
this video right here if you like to see
that full episode check out this video
here or if you'd like to dive deep into
the full private podcast subscribe via
the patreon link in the description your
support on patreon is what allows us to
keep this podcast 100% advertisement
free okay